we switch gears now and turn our
attention to East Palestine in Ohio
where chemicals Now cover the air and
land and waterways following that train
derailment and subsequent controlled
burn of many toxic chemicals on board
that train now we're getting multiple
reports of a lot of dead fish dead
animals and sick people but of course
U.S Transportation secretary pothole
Pete well he totally ignored the crisis
for days was shamed into making a
statement on Twitter late last night
quote I continue to be concerned about
the impacts of the February 3rd trained
derailment really here with the latest
he's actually on the ground where he
should have been in Ohio investigative
reporter Fox News contributor Sarah
Carter Is With Us Sarah you spent a lot
of time with community members today and
obviously they're upset they're
concerned they're worried what are they
telling you
Sean they are very concerned they are
very worried and they want answers uh
for not only from the government but
from Norfolk Southern Railroad I'm
actually here at The Parks and
Recreation Area Sean here in East
Palestine and you can see the caution
tape right here behind me and the creek
running behind me workers have been here
all day and night trying to clean out
this Creek bed with running water
Neighbors in the area some of the houses
have been left abandoned here for the
last 11 days they're afraid to come home
we have uh we spoke to some of those
neighbors and we also had an opportunity
to speak to the Chief from Mahoning
County he was the first person actually
at the scene on February 3rd when the
harrowing fire and explosion took place
I want you to take a listen to what he
had to say
talk about that night you were one of
the first people on the scene you
described it
I mean very literally as yeah the gates
of hell were open
um I responded for with Springfield
Township because I'm also a volunteer
fireman there and uh we were one of the
first Mutual Aid units on scene and uh
so we were fighting the fire and it was
hot you know and uh so it was a lot of
fire and there's a lot of stuff going on
and it was just it was unbelievable
everybody said that probably the
smartest thing to do was what happened
which is not allowing it to detonate on
its own to control that Nation what I
mean the pictures are astonishing I mean
it looks like a little nuclear bomb
going off I mean how how terrifying was
that well correct I mean if you didn't
if they didn't do what they did then you
would have had a blevy which is a
boiling liquid expanding Vapor explosion
so what happens is the pressure builds
up in a tank and when it explodes
shrapnel goes every direction for half
mile out to a mile so in order for that
to not happen that's why they did the
control release and burn so that that
explosion would not occur are you at all
concerned about the toxins that have
been spilled across uh Palestine very
much so I mean it's like half of my
family lives in East Palestine there's
been a lot of concern about animals that
have perished due to this yeah I have
yet to see a sparrow
I used to have them in my yard all the
time I've yet to see one I put bird
feeders out again today
any show up nope not yet do you trust
what they're saying do you believe that
it's okay no what's your worst concern
right now for the community especially
well you got all these toxins all the
chemicals basically that is going to
cause cancer we've all been exposed it's
not a one mile thing
it's gonna end up in the water it's
gripe what it's been like coming back
home and hearing about the animals and
the loss of life and yeah it's it's
certainly nerve-wracking it's it's just
the unknown is what it is that's the
worst part we just we don't know you
know what's the truth what's not the
truth what's you know over exaggerating
what's not you know we don't know what
is your hope for uh for Palestine and
and for the surrounding community
well I think they're doing the right
thing
but it's going to take a while it's
going to take a while
Sean thousands of fish have been found
dead in the rivers out here also uh
people have lost livestock they've lost
chickens foxes the neighbors are very
concerned there's a lot of children in
the area they say they want answers
there's actually going to be a town hall
tomorrow where the neighbors are going
to speak their piece and tell the
government that they want answers now as
well as Norfolk Southern they had no
idea everyone that I spoke to here that
chemical so toxic we're being driven
through their community on this train so
certainly the concern is high they're
worried about what's going to happen in
years to come and they also want to know
if any of those chemicals is seeped into
their Wells a lot of the families around
here actually have wells for water and
they're very concerned about that what
got into the soil what got into the
wells and if they're going to get it out
of their water
oh Sarah unbelievable
uh it well those First Responders I mean
we're looking at the videos and the
people that were on the ground when this
happened I mean literally they were like
right in the middle of the aftermath of
a chemical attack I mean these these
First Responders God only knows what
they got exposed to uh and and I hope
they're being looked at in the way they
should be now uh and God only knows what
the long-term impact is going to be here
but uh anyway Sarah we appreciate that
report hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else